here's what would happen if you fell  into a pool of snake venom if you were  to swim in snake venom there's a good  chance you wouldn't die first you'd  probably notice that swimming and snake  venom isn't very different than swimming  in water but wouldn't it smell well it  won't really smell like anything and if  you happen to accidentally taste the  Venom it would taste somewhat sweet  almost like a Tangy version of water  swimming and Venom really wouldn't do  anything to you unless of course you had  open wounds if you went in this pool  with any sort of cut you'd be in big  trouble the Venom would seep into your  veins quickly and give you a number of  issues mainly blood clotting this would  eventually clog your blood vessels and  would lead to you dying from a stroke or  a heart attack  maybe we shouldn't be swimming in this  stuff anyway even if it does no harm so